شكرا للزميل نايف مشاهدينا الكرام اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون في تغطيتنا
للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان هدنه
هشه تبادل فيها طرفاء الصراع الاتهامات
بخرقها الدعم السريع يقول ان الجيش هاجم
قواته بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض
المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد فيما يقول
الجيش ان الدعم السريع يستخدم المدنيين
دروعا بشريه هذا فيما رصد الجيش تحركات
كثيفه لارتال عسكريه من الدعم السريع تتجه
من كردفان ودارفور الى الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اذا ما تزال المواجهات مستمره حيث فشلت
الهدنه على ما يبدو في وقف اطلاق النار
بين الجيش والدعم السريع
الاشتباكات تركزت في العاصمه الخرطوم
وتحديدا في محيط القصر الرئاسي ومناطق في
محيط القياده العامه واداره المرافق
الاستراتيجيه التي تتعرض لقصف مدفعي
عشوائي وكذلك المناطق المحيطه بمطار
الخرطوم الدولي وحي المطار السكني وفقا
للجيش السوداني فان الاشتباكات تتمركز
ايضا في مناطق في بحري وام درمان
في هذه الاثناء تحدث الجيش السوداني عن
تحركات كثيفه لارتال عسكريه للدعم السريع
قادمه من كردفان ودارفور وذلك لتعزيز
قواتها في الخرطوم
كما اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع باستخدام المدنيين في الاحياء
السكنيه دروعا بشريه
للاستغلال استغلال ذاته بشع
التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب سعر الباص فضل
خمسه مقاعد لكن يعني ثلاثه نفر قلبي مليار
وخمسين مليار وخمسين
وفي المقابل حملت قوات الدعم السريع
المجتمع الدولي مسؤولياته اتجاه خرق
الهدنه من قبل قيادات الجيش السوداني
مشيره الى ان عدم التزام قيادات الجيش
بالهدنه
تؤكد تعدد مراكز القرار داخل الجيش كما
اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع قوات من الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري
وارض المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
هذا واظهرت الصور استمرار اغلاق المحل
التجاريه في السودان مع تواصل المواجهات
المسلحه بين الجيش والقوات الدعم السريعه
من جانبها عبرت بريطانيا عن قلقها ازاء
التقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفقاء
مره اخرى بالوفاء بالتزاماتهما حول الهدنه
ودعت قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار وانهاء العنف بالاضافه
الى السماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وضمان حمايه المدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني والطبي
من جانبه على يمينه العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتيريس دعا الاطراف المتصارعه في
السودان الى وقف القتال في البلاد مشددا
على ان القتال لن يكون حلا للصراع بين
هاتين القوتين وتراس دعا قاده السودان
لجعل مصالح شعبهم اولويه وان يقوموا
باسكات اسلحتهم فورا
[تصفيق]
ماشيين الهجوم
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودين المواطنين ماشيين
ماشيين
شرطه المحليه للمواطنين العاديين دارين
يمشوا ياخذوا لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه
لانه ما في قوه يعني تحميم
يحمي نفسه
الى الخرطوم الان لمزيد من المتابع ينضم
اليهم هناك الصحفي خالد الفكي سيد خالد
اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه من العربيه
هل سقطت الهدنه تماما ام ما زالت قائمه
ولو بشكل هش
نعم يعني يمكن القول ان الهدنه ولكن بشكل
ما سمعناه منذ الصباح في تحقيق للطيران
ايضا هناك
اشتباكات تدور في عدد من المناطق ابرزها
الان في محيط القياده الجيش في هذه اللحظه
يقول انا مجموعه كبيره من الدعم السريع
تحاول مجددا الهجوم على القياده العامه من
ناحيه الشرقيه للمطار الخرطوم ويبدو ان
التربه التي يوجهها في الصباح القران
الحربي الى موقع الركازات الدعم السريع في
المطار
السريع وهو الان يحاول الرد من خلال هذا
الهجوم ايضا يبدو ان الان الهدنه لم تعد
غائمه بشكل كبير في ظل سماع الدوي
انفجارات في عدد من الاحياء في ام درمان
وفي غربي جنوب ام درمان كذلك
ولكن النسبيه ايضا يمكن القول ان هذه
الهدنه هي افضل من سابقيها من السابقات
حيث ان الان هناك حركه نسبيه للمواطنين
المحاوله للتزود ببعض الحاجيات في ظل
بقائهم بفتره طويله داخل المنازل وايضا
محاوله كسر بقائهم ومحاوله ايضا البحث عن
مناطق امنه بعيده من من مناطق الصراع
والاشتباكات فاذا يمكن القول ان هذه
الهدنه هي هشه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه يمكن
ان تكون افضل من
تلك الاذن
طيب هل يمكن وسط هذه الظروف استاذ خالد
الحديث عن ممرات امنه يعني يمكن للناس
عبور هذه الممرات في طريق اجلائهم او
النزوح الى مناطق اخرى ام لا يمكن الحديث
عن ذلك يعني لانه في تبادل لاطلاق النار
بين الطرفين
الان المواطنين هم الذين يعني
يشكلون
يعني ملذات امنه وطرق امنه ولكنها ليس من
خلال اشراف الدعم السريع او القوات
المسلحه يعني الان اسرار المواطن السوداني
على محاوله استئناف الحياه بشكل ولو شيء
ولا فيه قليل من اليسرى محاوله للخروج من
الطوق هذه الحرب الان هناك مناطق بدره
الحصص الحيه في يعني دائره تبعد عن مناطق
الاشتباكاترين الى 25 كيلو الحياه بدات
تعود تدريجيا الى الى الى طبيعتها محاوله
فتح الاسواق محاوله ايضا يعني ايجاد النطق
الحياه هنا وهناك هناك الان شاهدنا عدد من
يعني من محطات الخدمه الان هي فيها عدد من
السيارات
يعني تقف تر بحثا عن الوقود فاذا الان
اعتقد ان المواطن هو يحاول التغلب يعني
معاركه الواقع بعيدا عن هذه الاثار
المدمره للحياه
متعلقه بهذه الحرب اللعينه يبدو ان المطر
السوداني يحاول ان يفرض واقع جديده ولا
يعدي بهذه الحرب التي هي الان تكاد ان تشل
حياته تماما
وربما اخرجت عدد كبير من المواطنين
السودانيه من مناظرهم وفضلوا
مغادره المغادره العبد من الولايات او
المغادره الى مصر شمال او الى اثيوبيا
شرقا او خلافه من المناطق التي يمكن ان
يكون فيها قليل من الامن فبالتالي اعتقد
ان المواطن هو الان الذي يحاول ان يبحث عن
طرق ومسارات امنه وليس القوات المسلحه او
الدعم السريع في ما زال فيما يظل الوضع
الانساني كارث والصحي والقطاع الصحي الان
يعني يقف على شفاء شفاء يعني الجبل وراء
الاوضاع المدريه مواطنه السوداني يتغلب
ويتعايش مع هذه الاوضاع طيب استاذ خالد
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء مع عيسى اعود اليك
بعد قليل
بالطبع تطورات عمليه الاجلاء من السودان
مستمره حيث يشهد مطار بورتسودان رحلات
اجلاء بواقع ثلاث رحلات جويه يوميا على
متنها مئات الرعايه من الدول الاجنبيه
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه والموظفين الامميين
وقد وصلت احدى طائرات الاجلاء الى بيروت
بمساعده السعوديه محمله ب 32 شخصا
كما تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث
مراحل بريه جويه وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال
بالحافلات الى بورتسودان ثم الى ميناء جده
وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره في طرابلس
وقد استقبل مطار معيتيقه الدولي 105 من
افراد الجاليه الليبيه في السودان بعد
اجلائهم
واكدت الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيه واثنين
سوريا وعدلا اخر من اعضاء الجاليه في
الخرطوم قدموا من مطار بورت سودان
من مدينه بورسودان مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي يتابع عمليات الاجلاء
نزار اهلا وسهلا بك كيف تسير عمليات
الاجلاء وابرز مشاهدات اليوم
نعم هذه
العمليه الان تمضي وفق التقديرات الموضوعه
من قبل الجيش ومن قبل الادارات المختلفه
هنا في مدينه بورسودان الشرق السودان عدد
من السفن الان وصلت الى مدينه بورسودان
لمواصلات الاجلاء التي بدات منذ الحادي
والعشرين من اكتوبر او من هذا الشهر عفوا
هذه العمليات ما زالت متواصله بواقع الست
الى خمس رحلات في اليوم تقوم هذه العبارات
وهذه القطع البحريه في ايصال كل
العالقين نزار لو سمحت يعني اذا
تستطيع ان تطلب من المصور
الكاميرا قليله لنشاهد الصوره بشكل افضل
هل من الممكن للمصور ان يحرك
الكاميرا لنرى الميناء ولنرى السفن ولنرى
يعني بعض النازحين الذين تم اجلائهم اذا
كان ذلك ممكنا
نزار هل تسمعني
يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع نزار لا عوده
اليه بطبيعه الحال اعود الى السيد خالد
الفقي من
الخرطوم استاذ خالد هل عرف مصير الرئيس
السابق عمر حسن البشير وعدد من اركان
نظامه هل عرف لان الاتهامات متبادله بين
الطرفين
الذي اصدره الجيش السوداني وقال ان الرئيس
البشير بصحبه عدد من قيادات نظامي وهم
الان داخل مستشفى صلاح الطبي منذ فتره
يتلقون العلاج هناك وان الجيش السوداني
ليس هو مسؤول من هذه الاجراءات بل هناك
اجراءات تتعلق باداره السجون والشرطه هم
المسؤولين من توفير الحمايه وحراسه
الحراسه لكل الذين هم نزلاء في السيون
وبالتالي يعني ينفي فديه ان يكون
الاسلاميين هم وراء اي تحركات للجيش او اي
مشاركه في هذه الحرب ضد الدعم السريع
فبالتالي هو يتبرع من محاولاتهم وقال
صراحه ان الدعم السريع هو
يعني صنيعه النظام البائد وان ما يجري
الان هو يتحمل النظ
سيد صلاح هل تسمعني
انقطع ايضا الاتصال بالطبع يبدو هنالك
مشكله في الاتصالات مع السودان في هذه
الاوقات لا نعود سواء الى السيد صلاح او
الى مراسلين نزار بقداوي من بورسودان على
كل نتابع هذه التغطيه حول جهود السعوديه
بشان المساهمه في اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
عبر موانئ جذاب البحر الاحمر وصلت الفرقات
الفرنسيه الى جده وعلمتنها اكثر من 400
شخص قادمين من السودان هربا من الاقتتال
الدائر
السياق اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه ان
سفينه تقل الفن وستمائه
وسبعه وثمانين مدنيا من اكثر من خمسين
دوله فروا من العنف في السودان قد وصلت
الى السعوديه الاربعاء في اكبر عمليه
انقاذ من نوعها تنفذها المملكه حتى الان
وزاره الخارجيه وفي بيان الله اكدت حرص
المملكه على توفير كامل الاحتياجات
الاساسيه للرعايه الاجانب تمهيدا لتسهيل
مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
الان بدا نزول
الاشخاص على متن او رعايه بعثته هموم
المتحده ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي
ترافقها احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس
من حرس الحدود وكذلك جود من حرس الحدود
يرافقونها في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه
الاولى طبعا الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات
الطبيه هم يقومون به الان النزول والمتوجه
مباشره الى مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي
خصصتها الصحه وهي هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي وكذلك السلطات السعوديه وتامين
صحه وسلامه رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده تحمل
هذه الفرقاطه قرابه ال400 شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه هناك السلك الدبلوماسي لعدد من
الدول سواء الدول من اوروبا وكذلك امريكا
وهم ايضا سوف يستقبلون بعض رعاياهم من
بعثه الامم المتحده يتواجدون الان هنا على
رصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول او
نزول ايضا المزيد من بعثه الامم المتحده
ورعايه بعثته الامم المتحده الذين وصلوا
للتو الان
هذا وساهمت سفينه امان السعوديه باجلاء
مئات الاشخاص من مختلف جنسيات العالم
مسجله بذلك اكبر عمليه اجلاء من السودان
حتى الان نتعرف على هذه السفينه
امان السعوديه تقوم باكبر عمليه اجلاء من
السودان السفينه ترفع علم السعوديه منذ 44
عاما
ايطاليه الصنع تملكها شركه نماء للتجاره
الدوليه عرضها يصل الى 23 مترا وطولها ل
مئات الرعايه الاجانب استخدموها لتنقلهم
من ميناء سواكن الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده يصلون لوجهتهم المستقره
وتغمرهم فرحه النجاه يلوحون لها شكرا
امانه على الامانه
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع مذيعه يا محمد
معانا يعني
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان فيه يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما قال
لنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني
منظم ما شاء الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم
قاعدين يعطونه ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع
جدا سهل الحمد لله
تواصلوا معاهم قالوا قالوا لهم نروح على
الميناء البري البحري
ما حنطلع من بيوتنا من بيوتنا ما حنطلع
أحنا هنموت في بيوتنا الموت واحد احنا
اولادنا بيقوموا من الصبح عشان يجيبوا لنا
مويه لغايه بالليل مويه عشان نشرب نحن
[موسيقى]
حد وين يا حماتي يا اخي خافوا الله فينا
خافوا الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم اليه من هناك من
راس العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم اهلا وسهلا
بك اخر التطورات الميدانيه وهل انهارت
الهدنه
نعم باخر كلمه ذكرتها وهي انهيار الهدنه
بالفعل الهدنه انهارت لانه الان تجددت
الاشتباكات مره اخرى بعده هدوء الاحوال
النسبيهم في مناطق متفرقه منه العاصمه
الخرطوم وتحديدا في مدينه ام درمان التي
انا اتواجد بها الان في هذه المدينه تجددت
الاشتباكات في مناطق متفرقه من النواحي
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه كذلك في مناطق محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون وكذلك
جهه الفتيحه ومحيط هذه المنطقه من
المهندسين سمعت اصوات مضادات الطائرات في
هذه المناطق كذلك سمعت المدافع قبل ثلاث
ساعات تقريبا من الان وقبل قليل وصلتني
ايضا اخبار انه هناك اصوات
لتلك المناطق لكن سقط اصوات للطلاق ناريه
في هذه المنطقه
ايضا كانت هناك طائرات تجوب سماء الخرطوم
بالتحديد في هذه المناطق تستهدف لكل تاكيد
المواقع التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريعه
ما هي المعلومات التي تصلكم من المعارك في
محيط المقر مقر القياده العامه وايضا في
محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون وايضا
المطار اذا كانت تصلك اي معلومات محدثه
سالم
نعم المعلومات صحيحه في ظل الاتصالات
والانترنت المتذبذب حقيقه لكن بكل تاكيد
ان هذه المناطق ظلت تتواجد بها قوات الدعم
السريع وظلت كذلك قوات الجيش السوداني هي
دائما مجتهده في حصر هذه القوات في تلك
المناطق وهذا ما يفهم من كل الاحاديث التي
الاحاديث التي نسمعها من قاده الجيش
السوداني كذلك هذه المناطق يجب ان يعني ان
نتحدث عنها من الناحيه المهمه جدا وهي
مساله السكان في تلك المناطق المناطق في
محيطه لدعوه التلفزيون او حتى المناطق في
محيط القياده العامه او حتى مطار الخرطوم
السكان غالبيتهم خرجوا من تلك المناطق هذه
ناحيه الناحيه الاخرى ان هذه المناطق تجوب
فيها يعني بعض من قوات الدعم السريع خاصه
محيط مطار الخرطوم كل الاحياء المحيطه به
كذلك فالسكان هربوا من تلك المناطق وشكوا
من عديد من الاعمال المرعبه في تلك
المناطق عطا على ما فيها من اشتباكات
واطلاق نيران وغيرها انها ايضا تشهد اعمال
نهب وسلب في الليل
طيب هنالك حديث سالم بدا يتواتر عن بدء
انتشار اوبئه وامراض في الخرطوم في ضوء
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء هل هذا صحيح ام
في الامر مبالغه
نعم هذا الامر تؤكده وزاره الصحه وتنفيه
لان هذا امر كهذا الا ان يصدر به بصوره
رسميه لكن ما نؤكده ان اننا تحدثنا منذ
بدايه هذه الازمه وتحدث حتى الذين يكونوا
مختصون في هذا الجانب في الموضوع بموضوع
الاوبئه والامراض بحكم هذه المياه التي
يشربها وانا كنت شاهد عيان على منطقه بحري
رايت كثير من المواطنين يشربون مياه غير
صالحه للشرب لانه لا توجد مياه غيرها
ويستخدمونها كذلك لاستخدامات اخرى هذا
الامر بالفعل هو ينذر بكارثه اذا لم يتم
تدارك الامر بمياه صحيه انا يعني احياء
كثيره جدا تفتقر للمياه واحياء كثيره جدا
تفتقر ايضا للكهرباء حتى هذا اليوم سالم
عندما تجول سواء في ام درمان او في غيرها
من المناطق هل جميع المحال التجاريه مقفله
ام لا في محل يعني بدات يعني او فتحت
ابوابها
ليست كل المحل التجاريه مغلقه المحل
التجاريه المغلقه بالكامل هي في المناطق
التي
تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات وفيها المظاهر
العسكريه ظاهره هذه المناطق يحرص
التجار او البائعون ان يغلقوا محالهم
لانها لا تصبح امنه في ظل هذا الوجود
والاشتباكات وتبادل اطلاق النار لكن حينما
نبتعد قليلا عن هذه المناطق الى مناطق
اخرى نجد الحياه شبه طبيعيه انا الان في
واحده من مناطق من الرمان والحياه فيها
شبه طبيعيه الحركه كذلك شبه طبيعيه هناك
محل تجاريه كثيره تعمل لكن يشكو اصحاب هذه
المحال من شح في بعض المواد الغذائيه
وتوفرها يشكون ايضا من عدم القدره على ان
يطالبوا بامداد اخر من مناطق مختلفه من
اجل ان يوصلوا هذه المواد الى المقالات
والمحله التجاريه التي يعملون فيها بحكم
مشكله الوقود ومشكله الطرق كذلك من انظر
ما مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا
لك سالم على كل هذه المتابعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في رئاسه الشرطه
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودينا المواطنين
ماشيين ماشيين قال لهم فتحوا لهم المخازن
بتاعه شرطه المحليه
شرطه المحليه
من شرطه المحليه لانه ما في قوه يعني
تحميم اي زول امشي يحمي نفسه
واعود اعزائي المشاهدين الى من قطع من
حواري مع مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي من
بورتسودان حيث يتابع عمليات الاجلاء نزار
اهلا وسهلا بك مجددا اذا كنت تسمعني كيف
تسير عمليات الاجلاء وعدد سفن الاجلاء
التي وصلت اليوم الى بورسودان
نعم كنا قبل قليل نتحدث في احد المراسي
هنا في مدينه بورسودان تحديدا في الميناء
الاخضر بالميناء الشمالي
باخره او قطعتان حربيتان بحريتان وصلتا
صباح هذا اليوم الى ميناء يتبعان لدوله
الصين
يستعدان لاجلاء النحو 600 من رعايه الصين
هنا في بورسودان وصلوا خلال اليومين
الماضيين اما هنا فهذه القطع البحريه
العسكريه الهنديه ايضا قبل قليل اكتملت
كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه بالدخول رعايه
دوله الهند في اطار مراحل مختلفه تعلم بان
عدد الجاليه الهنديه في السودان يقدر بنحو
4000 نحو 1200 قرروا ان يغادروا السودان
جراء الاشتباكات والاعمال
اعمال العنف التي تحدث في عدد من المناطق
الان هذه الباخره تحوي نحو 350 من رعايه
دوله الهند
كافه عمليات الاجراء المتعلقه
بالمغادره والان هذه الباخره يبدو انها
تعلن كل الطاقم بانها على اهبه الاستعداد
لمغادره هذا المرسى والتوجه مباشره الى
عمق البحر الاحمر وربما الى جده ومنها الى
عدد من المناطق ووصولا الى دوله الهند على
كل الاحوال هذه العمليه الان تمضي بدات
عمليات الاجلاء البحري منذ الحادي
والعشرين وما زالت مستمره بواقع الثلاثه
الى خمس رحلات بحريه في اليوم اما الجانب
الجوي في اطار المسار الثاني لعمليات
الاجلاء تمضي عمليه الاجلاء منذ الثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر وتستمر بواقع 6 الى
8 رحلات للطيران العسكري الذي يهبط
باستمرار على مهبط مطار بورسودان الدولي
لاجلاء النحو الف شخص يوميا حسب ما اكدت
اداره مطار بورسودان الدولي
فبنزار
وسط الحديث عن انهيار الهدنه وكم هي
المسافه يعني لنقل من وسط الخرطوم او من
ام درمان للوصول الى ميناء بورسودان
انقطع الاتصال الهاتفي لن استطيع ان اواصل
حتى استمع للسؤال الاخر ولكن ساجيب على
هذا التساؤل المتعلق بمسار الرحله سواء
كانت من الخرطوم ام من عدد من المدن وصولا
الى شرق السودان من وصل الى مدينه
بورسودان بشرق السودان
مضى في رحله استقرقت نحو اثنتي عشره ساعه
على الطريقه البري سواء بدات من الخرطوم
مرورا بمدينه وادمدني جنوبا ومنها الى
مدينه القضارف في شرق السودان ومدينه كسلا
بشرق الصودا ايضا وصولا الى مدينه
بورسودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر اما الذين
اختاروا الطريق الثاني فهو يبدا من مدينه
بورسودا يبدا من مدينه الخرطوم
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مجددا مع مراسل
العربيه من بورسودان نزار بقداوي بالطبع
هنالك مشكله في الاتصالات مع السودان
نتيجه هذا الاقتتال الدائر بالطبع يعني لا
وجود الكهرباء او ماء وحتى خدمات الانترنت
والاتصالات هي شبه معطله او فيها مشاكل
كثيره على كل هذه التغطيه متواصله من قناه
العربيه وفي متابعات عمليات الاجلاء ايضا
اعزائي المشاهدين اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الالمانيه انها انتهت من عمليات الاجلاء
من السودان نضحتا انها نقلت اكثر من 700
شخص الى خارج السودان بينهم 200 مواطن
الماني
اما واشنطن فقال مسؤول في البحريه
الامريكيه لشبكه ان الولايات المتحده
سترسل س
فينه حربيه ثالثه الى السودان تمتاز بسرعه
عاليه نسبيا وذلك بعد يوم واحد من اعلان
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن وصول سفينه
للسواحل السودانيه وتوجه اخرى من بحر
العرب الى هناك
واضاف المسؤول البحري ان السفن الثلاث
قادره على نقل مئات الاطنان من المعدات
وعدد كبير من الافراد
بسرعه عاليه
وفي تداعيات هروب عدد من رموز النظام
السابق من سجن كوبر بالعاصمه الخرطوم اكد
الجيش السوداني ان رئيس السابق عمر حسن
البشير ما يزال محتجزا بمستشفى عسكري تحت
حراسه الشرطه القضائيه وقال الجيش في بيان
له ان البشير وعددا من قيادات نظامه
محتجزون في مستشفى علياء العسكري
الجيش عبر عن رفضه لاي محاولات لربط ما
يجري في السجون بمزايدات على مواقفه
الوطنيه
ووصف الجيش السوداني الدعم السريع
والقائده بانه من امتداد للنظام السابق
اما شرطه السودانيه فحملت قوات الدعم
السريع مسؤوليه اطلاق سراح السجناء
بالاضافه الى الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المواطنين واكدت الشرطه ان الدعم السريع
اطلق سراحه النزلاء في سته سجون بالخرطوم
والولايات الاخرى
الشرطه قالت ايضا ان قوات الدعم السريع
اقتحمت سجن كوبر وتسببت في قتله وجرح عدد
من افراد الشرطه
وفي المقابل اتهم المستشار السياسي لقائد
القوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت اتهم قيادات
المواليه للبشير في الجيش بالمسؤوليه عن
اطلاق سراحي قيادات النظام السابق من سجن
كوبر
واضاف في تصريحاته للعربيه انا مغادره
القيادات نظام البشير للسجن كان امرا
متوقعا ولد اليوم الاول لانقلاب الحركه
الاسلاميه الذي يدبره على الكرتي نتوقع كل
هذا العناصر الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا لا
اتهم كل الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه اسلاميه
هنالك ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهات داخل
الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك الجهات الضباط
اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراح
هذه المجموعه ونحن لدينا معلومات من داخل
السجن لحظه باطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام
السجن لحظه اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا
لم تكن قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه
عزه قال ايضا للعربيه ان من مسؤوليه الدعم
السريع القاء القبض على من فرو من داخل
سجن كوبر
لا لا ليس لدي معلومه عن كيفيه تنفيذ
العمليه او كيفيه اخلاقه من السجن اؤكد لك
هذا هذا مجرد توقعات او احتمالات او لا
اشخاص فيهم احمد هارون في يوم عبد الرحيم
محمد
الشعب السوداني طوال 30 سنه نحن من
مسؤوليتنا وفي اطار حربنا
والذي يواجهونا بها من مسؤوليتنا سنسعى
بكل ما يمكن ان نقبض القبض عليهم
وبالحديث عن سجن كوبرا الذي غادرت منه
قيادات من نظام البشير ابرزهم احمد هارون
فهذا السجن يقع في بحر بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويبعد عن المستشفى العسكري نحو 10
كيلومترات اي حوالي 17 دقيقه بالسياره
وبحسب الجيش السوداني يرقد الرئيس السابق
في المستشفى العسكري تحت رقابه امنيه قبل
اندلاع الاشتباكات
اقدم سجنا في السودان افتتح عام
1903 يقع في حي كوبر بمدينه بحري قرب
النيل الازرق نسب اسمه الى الجنرال
البريطاني كوبر الذي تولى اداره السجن
مساحته 5000 متر مربع وتصميمه يحاكي سجون
بريطانيا يضم محكومين سياسيين وجنائيين
وشهد اشهر اعدامات الضباط [__] 14 قسما من
بينها قسم مخصص للمدانين باحكام الاعدام
وقسم لاصحاب السوابق واخر لذوي الاحكام
الطويله والقصيره وقسم للمعتقلين
السياسيين كان يضم الرئيس السابق البشير
وعددا من قيادات نظامه غادره عدد من
قيادات نظام البشير على خلفيه التدهور
الامني في البلاد
بلندن ينضم اليه لمزيد من المتابع
والتحليل الكاتب الصحفي السوداني خالد
الاعسر سيد خالد اهلا وسهلا بك هل تعتقد
ان الهدنه سقطت تماما ام لا ما زال يؤمل
بتعويمها وتمديدها
نعمل ان تستمر الهدنه وان يتم الالتزام
بها من كل الاطراف ولكن من خلال النظر
لعدد الهدن التي يعلنت في الايام الماضيه
والفشل الذي صاحب هذه الهدن لا يمكن
التنبؤ بنجاح اي هدنه لاحقا خاصه وان نرجع
الكف العسكريه ترجح لصالح الجيش في سيطره
للولايات ويعني انتشار كثيف في الخرطوم
وهذا التقدم عسكري ربما قوه الدعم السريع
وحتى امس هي تحاول ان تدخل بعض القوات في
صياغه المعركه وهذا ينوم على انها لم تكن
جاده في موضوع الهدن التي اعلنت من قبل
ولكن الدعم السريع يقول العكس انه يسيطر
على اكثر المناطق والمواقع في الخرطوم
تعرف يعني في الحرب الحقيقه يعني اول
الضحايا أستاذ خالد لانه كل طرف يتحدث عن
تقدم وعن انتصارات ولا يوجد يعني مصادر
مستقله لنستقي منها المعلومات بشكل اوفى
بالنسبه الى
يعني حركه النزوح عمليات الاجلاء الكبرى
التي نراها بهذا الشكل الا تشير او تستبطن
بان كل الدول باتت لديها قناعه بان هذه
الحرب ستطول وتطول وستعنف في المرحله
المقبله ام لا لا يمكن قول ذلك
[موسيقى]
على الواقع السوداني والشعب السوداني
ونشهد في ذلك بان المجتمع الدولي الفاعل
في عمليه اجلاء الرعايه الان من السودان
وكان فاعلا يعني يمارس اختراقات كبيره
ويتصرف طولا وعرضا في السياسه والساحه
السياسيه السودانيه وما انحاء جاءت لحظه
الحقيقه لم يهتم سوى ان يسحب مواطني وفي
ذلك رساله بليغه للشعب السوداني قبل
المجتمع الدولي ان هؤلاء الذين
باسمكم ان هؤلاء الذين كانوا يرفعون
شعارات السعي لايجاد حلول ناجعه الازمه
السودانيه ليسوا عليون الان بما الشعب
السوداني من دمار ومن تقدير ومن تشريد
المجتمع الدولي بكل اسف يعني على كل في كل
صباح يتجلى شكل الحقيقي ويظهر بوجهه
الحقيقي وهو الذي لا يريد اي مصلحه للشعب
السوداني هم اجعل فطير الحرب بالاستعانه
باجنداتهم وفي مخالبهم داخل المنظومه
المجتمعيه والسياسيه السودانيه وما انطلقت
الطلقه الاولى لم لم يكترسوا لاي شيء لم
يهتم هربوا واخرجوا معهم رعايهم وتركوا
الجمل بما حمل الشعب السوداني ان يعاني
الامرين هذه هي الصوره الحقيقيه يعني هل
تريد ان تقول ان هذه الحرب ستطول وتعنف لم
تطول لن تطول بواقع القوه العسكريه وميزان
القوه والسيطره هناك جيش تعرض لمؤامره
بمكونه من عشرات الالاف من الجنود المتجين
بالسلاح انا اقرر هذه المساله اذا حدثت
هذه الحادثه في اي دوله اوروبيه حتى في
الدول الكبرى كحال الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انشر فيها ستين الف جندي مسلحين
بكل العساد العسكري في لحظه واحده ليهجم
على المدن لن تستطيع امريكا ولا روسيا ولا
اليابان ولا بريطانيا التي يقيم فيها شخص
واحد يهز المجتمع الامني كله في راي اخر
استاذ خالد معنا انه هذه الحرب فتحت لكي
تبقى وليس ليتم وقفها بشكل سريع والدليل
يعني 12 يوما من الاقتتال ولم يستطع الجيش
الحسم يعني حتى في محيط مقر القياده
العامه لا يوجد حسم في محيط لا يوجد حسم
ما زالت المعارك مستمره في محيط مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون كيف ترد يعني او كيف
ترى هذه المساله ايضا يعني
اما السريع قبل اندلاع هذه الحرب باربع
سنوات هذه المواقع الثلاثه التي ذكرتها
العصر الجمهوري القياده العامه والتلفزيون
القومي السوداني الهيئه العامه رايت بامه
عيني هذه القوات موجوده منذ 2019 وهذه هي
الماسه ان هذه القوات كانت موجوده كغوات
حمايه وحراسه وما انجاز ساعه الصيفيه اخذت
بعض الفيديوهات وزعمت بانها تسيطر واحتلت
هذه المواقع لا هي لم تحتل وانما كانت
موجوده في الاساس منظار بعد سنوات ولكن
انا كما ذكرت ان الجيش يتعامل مع الحاله
الانسانيه والحاله ويتوخد دقه في عدم
اصابه المواقع الاستراتيجيه والتدمير
البنى التحتيه ولكنه يعمل على قدم وشغل
لتخليص السودان من هذا الهم ونحن هنا لسنا
في سياق معرفه عسكريه بالمناسبه نحن لا
نريد لطرف ان يهزم الطرف نحن نريد لك اي
طرف ان يحكم صوت العقل وان ينظر للمشهد
السوداني من واقع مصلحه وانه طرف يجب ان
حاميا للدوله السودانيه وحريصا على امنيه
واستقرارها وعدم تدوير المنشاتها وليس
العكس ولكن اذا كانت
الحاله تستد
عي للكثيفه انا استطيع ان اؤكد لكن الجيش
السوداني لا يستحق حتى الان الا 15 الى
20% من قدرات العسكريه وهو يريد ان يحسم
هذه المعركه ويصغر رؤيه تحقن الدم
السوداني قبل ان تكون اللغه فيها لغه
البارود والدمار والتكسير ولكن نغادر على
ان يمسح كل هذه المواقع في سعد سعد زمن
ولكنه
لا يريد يا صغيره اسلحه موجيه بالريموت
كنترول يستخدم الاقمار الصناعيه يتابع
عمليه
الاستخباراتيه عبر القمر الصناعي نستطيع
ان اقول لك ذلك الان وهذا امر هذا امر
يؤكد وخالفه الجيش السوداني الذي لا يريد
ان
دعمك كمكون مجتمعي ومكون عسكري ولا يريد
هذه الطاقات
ويقتل هؤلاء الابرياء نحن نراشد الحس
الوطني القومي السوداني لكي يستغل كل هذه
الاشياء
خالد بهذا القدر من لندن الكاتب الصحفي
خالد الاعسر شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
حاصل يعني استغلال استغلال ذاته بشع من
التذكره الصباح بسعر والنسب سعر الباص
فظلو خمسه مقاعد لكن يعني
الشبكات المستمره قالت نقابه اطباء
السودان في بيانها اليومي ان عدد الوفيات
بين المدنيين ارتفع الى
295 حاله وفاه بينما تم تسجيل
1790 حاله اصابه بين المدنيين منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات وذكرت النقابه ان هناك العديد
من الاصابات والوفيات غير مشموله لعدم
التمكن من الوصول للمستشفيات لصعوبه
التنقل والوضع الامني في البلاد
من جانبه قال الناطق باسم الهلال الاحمر
السوداني اسامه ابو بكر في حديث للعربيه
ان الصيدليات في العاصمه الخرطوم مغلقه مع
وجود امدادات شحيحه في الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه واضاف ان مستشفيات
العاصمه تعاني بسبب شح الوقود الضروري
للمولدات الكهربائيه عدا عن النقص الكبير
في الطواقم الطبيه
المستشفيات الان زي ما انتم كلكم عارفين
في التقارير بتاعتكم انه فيها جدا في كل
الاشياء من ابسط المعينات او المستلزمات
الطبيه للعلاجات الى
القطوعات بتاعه الكهرباء والماء
وصعوبه تشغيل مولدات الطاقه الكهربائيه
لانه في شحف الوقود اللي بيشغل هذه
المولدات فيش في نقص كبير جدا جدا في
الكوادر الطبيه الملكه يعني الاطباء
والمساعدين والجراحين ومساعدين الطبيين
والممرضين
في وضع كارثي جدا وفي نفس الوقت الاعداد
بتاعه المصابين
والمتوفين كبيره جدا
ابو بكر اشاره في حديث العربيه الى وجود
نقص حاد في المواد التموينيه مشيرا لانه
اذا استمر الوضع طويلا فقد تحصل مجاعه في
العاصمه السودانيه وذلك لتوقف سلاسل
الانتاج في المصانع والمخابد
المعاناه في المواد التموينيه طبعا
المواد التموينيه واذا استمر الوضع لا قدر
الله على هذا المنوال لزمن شويه طويل
هتحصل مجاعه اكيد في الخرطوم لانه تعطلت
سلاسل الانتاج يعني المخابز
بسموها هي المصانع اللي تطحن الدليل
للتوزيع لنقاط التوزيع وللمخابز ففي شح
كبير جدا جدا
كارثه المستشفيات في السودان تلقي بظلالها
على الوضع الانساني حيث تتعرض النساء
الحوامل لخطوره بالغه بسبب عدم تلقيهم
الرعايه الطبيه اللازمه نتابع
نساء السودان في خطر الحوامل لا يعرفن
مصيرهن
لن يتمكن من الحصول على الرعايه الطبيه
اللازمه حوالي 220 الف امراه حامل معرضات
للخطر
توقف اكثر من 50 مستشفى عن الخدمه
ثانيه العيد
غرف الطوارئ تعج بالجرحى
احتل طرف الصراع عددا من المستشفيات وفق
نقابه اطباء السودان تتعرض مصانع ادويه
لعمليات نهب مستمره حاليا عندنا نقص يعني
في
كل المعدات الجراحيه وفي الدم وحتى
الاكسجين قطع عندنا يعني ان العيانين هنا
في العنايه البسيطه الاكسجين ما عندهم
كارثه المستشفيات ما زالت مستمره دون توقف
ومع انهيار القطاع الصحي جراء المواجهات
تعاني مشارح الخرطوم من ضعف الساعه
الاستيعابيه بعد ان ظلت مئات الجثثيل
مكدسه فيها لاكثر من ثلاثه اعوام ياتي ذلك
فيما تهدد مخلفات الحرب من اكوام قمامه
متفشيه في الشوارع تهدد بوجود ازمتين صحيه
وبيعيه
[موسيقى]
ملقون على جنبات شوارع السودان منكبون على
ظهورهم او بطونهم لا فرق
هذا احد تقاطعات حي الحلفايه يلفظ جثثا
مرميه على الاطراف
لايام وما زالت اجسادهم تربك الطرقات
يمشون بجانبها متجاهلين ان انفاسها انقطعت
وبل من القصف يعرقل سبل نقل رفاتهم فالحي
منهم لا يجرؤ على الذهاب بجثامينهم الى
المشرحه
لتكدوسها وايضا خشيه ان ترديه رصاصه ظلت
طريقها اليه فلا هدنه تفي بالحياه
[موسيقى]
من هنا تنبعث رائحه موت اخر تفوح منه ازمه
صحيه وبيئيه ففي مستشفى الساحه مثلا يتجمع
الجرح من قوه الدعم السريع لكن الكادر
الطبي يعجز عن معالجه الاعداد المتزايده
من الاصابات استمرار نزف احدهم يشي بزياده
عدد القتلى وتضاف اليه عباره كارثيه لا
متسعه لمزيد من الجثث في مشارح الخرطوم
التي تكابد اعدادهم لثلاث سنوات
فمنها جثث تعفنت واخرى تحللت اما عن
رائحتها فحدث ولا حرج
مخلفات الحرب تهدد السودان وتضعه في
تحديات معقده فهناك نفايات بالاكوام
تتكاثر فيها فرص انتشار الامراض المعديه
والجرثوميه لتكاثر الحشرات والذباب حولها
وانبعاث الروائح الكريهه هي المصائب هكذا
لا تاتي فرادى على السودان حرب ضروس محمله
بازمتين صحيه وبيئيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
هذا وسائده الحدود التشاديه السودانيه
وصولا حوالي 20 لاجئ سوداني منذ اندلاع
الحرب في السودان
ورصدت مشاهد في تشاد للاوضاع الانسانيه
الصعبه التي يعيشها السودانيون مع لجوء
عدد كبير من النساء والاطفال وسط انعدام
ابسط مقومات الحياه هناك
[موسيقى]
احنا ما حنطلع من بيوتنا من بيوتنا معها
نطلع
الموت واحد احنا اولادنا نقوموا من الصباح
عشان يجيبوا لنا مويه لغايه بالليل مويه
عشان نشرب نحن مع العقليه حد وين يا ابو
حد وين يا حماتي يا اخي خافوا الله فينا
خافوا الله فينا لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
الزول يدعيكم شنو الامه كلها
[موسيقى]
قال مسؤولون بالامم المتحده ان المنظمه
تضع خطه لاستقبال مئات الالاف من الذين
يتدفقون عبر الحدود السودانيه هربا من
العنف ومع تواصل النزاع في السودان يستمر
خروج الالاف من البلاد عبر عده مسارات وسط
ظروف صعبه
تركوا الحرب وراءهم بحثا عن طريق للخروج
من السودان الاف الاشخاص من عشرات
الجنسيات غادروا للوصول الى بر الامان
وعبر وجهات مختلفه كثيرون وجدوا ما تسنى
لهم من وسائل مغادره السودان بحرا او جوا
في حين لجا اخرون للطريق الاصعب بقطع
الجغرافيا السودانيه برا للدول المجاوره
مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين في تشاد اعلنت ان
عشرين الف لاجئ وصلوا الى هذا البلد مع
توقعات بان يتبعهم مئه الف اخرون في اسوا
الحالات اما في جنوب السودان فترجح
التقديرات الامميه نزوح ما يصل الى 170
الف شخص ثلاثه ارباعهم من لاجئ جنوب
السودان الذين سيعودون في رحله نزوح جديده
لكن في بلدهم هذه المره حتى من وجدوا
دولهم او دوله ثالثه تمد لهم يد العون فهم
يعانون الامرين لمغادره السودان في رحله
محفوفه بالمشاق تليها نقاط توقف مؤقته لمن
غادروا برا الى مصر او جوا الى جيبوتي او
بحرا عبر بورسودان وصولا الى السعوديه
حسن جوليد العربيه
وفي اخر تطورات الاوضاع الميدانيه اعلن
الجيش السوداني التصدي لهجوم لقوات الدعم
السريع على مقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه في الخرطوم وقال الجيش انه كبد
قوات الدعم السريع خسائر فادحه بحسب
البيان
واتهم الجيش قوات الدعم السريع بمواصله
خرق الهدنه المعلومه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودين المواطنين ماشيين
ماشيين قال لهم
فتحت شرطه المحليه
شرطه المحليه للمواطنين العاديين دايرين
يمشوا ياخذوا لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه
لانه ما في قوه يعني تحميم اي زول امشي
يحمي نفسه
تبادل اطراف القتال في السودان بشكل متكرر
اتهامات بخرق الهدنات التي تم الاتفاق
عليها ولم يتم احترامه اي منها في ظل
مناشدات دوريه بوقف القتال
من خلق الهدنه
الطرف الاخر
تبادل الاتهامات بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بات كتبادل اطلاق النار جزء من يوميات
الحرب الدائره رحاها في شوارع الخرطوم
هدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه ما انطلقت حتى
بدات البيانات بالصدور تاره من الجيش الذي
قال انه رصد استمرار التحركات العسكريه
لقوات الدعم داخل وخارج العاصمه ومحاوله
السيطره على مواقع وتقييد تحركات
المواطنين بالاضافه الى حركه كثيفه
بمجموعات متفاوته نحو مصفاه الجيل للسيطره
عليها وخلق ازمه في امدادات الوقود بكامل
البلاد
قوه الدعم السريع من خلال حسابها على
تويتر شجبت انتهاك الجيش الهدنه متهمه
اياه بالقيام بالقصف العشوائي الامر الذي
يعرض حياه المدنيين للخطر هذا الشد والجذب
تزامن مع امال الجهات الدوليه في نجاح
الهدنه حيث حث مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل من خلال
حسابه في تويتر الطرفين على الالتزام حتى
يتم التوصل لوقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه
واقامه ممرات انسانيه لحمايه المدنيين
اوعد الابرياء اما واشنطن حسب وزير
خارجيتها انتوني بلينكين فهي تعمل مع
شركائها لتشكيل لجنه تتفاوض على وقف دائم
لاطلاق النار في السودان
البرهان ودجلو حليفا الامس عدوا اليوم
اللذان تسبب صراعهما على السلطه حتى الان
في قتل اكثر من
459 شخصا حسب الصحه العالميه التي قدرت ان
اعداد الضحايا اكثر من هذا الرقم بكثير اذ
لم يتم احصاء القتلى في مناطق كثيره بسبب
القصف الكثيف انس نماسي العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات